This is a beautiful clip, I think you're going
to like this one, and this is really informative,
this will open up a conversation that I think is
a really important one to be having. Fox News host
Lou Dobbs, Fox Business, Fox News.
We can still say Fox Business host
Lou Dobbs was visibly confused about why they just
can't seem to find any evidence of all the voter
fraud that he is damn sure took place. So let's
look at the clip first and then we'll discuss.
And we still don't have verifiable,
tangible support for the for the
the crimes that everyone knows we're committed,
that is defrauding other citizens who voted with
fraudulent votes. We know that's the case in
Nevada. We know it's a case in Pennsylvania
and a number of other states. But we have had
a double of a time finding actual proof of
why this this is just perfect.
So Lou Dobbs has been one of
the biggest promulgates and platforms of
completely deranged, hairbrained fraud,
conspiracy theories on Fox News and Fox Business.
He's platformed that wacky lawyer, Sydney Powell.
He's platformed so-called witnesses to voter
fraud who couldn't actually come up with any
real claims of anybody doing anything wrong. And
now, after all of that, Lou, just isn't sure why
they can't find any actual proof of it's always
just out of reach. The proof that they need. Now,
a more sensible approach would be, well,
damn, if there are 100 different claims,
about 100 different types of fraud, and
I can find no evidence for any of them.
Maybe the fraud doesn't exist, but the absence of
evidence becomes part of the conspiracy theory.
And we've talked about that before more generally.
And this is actually one of the important signals
that you're dealing with, conspiracy theorists
for whom facts and evidence don't actually matter.
Healthy skepticism about the world is good.
Bottomless skepticism is not so good. And with
conspiracy theorists, once they've decided
what went down, if they can't find evidence,
the fact that they can't find evidence becomes
part of the reason they are skeptical. It cannot
be proven wrong. It is indefeasible if evidence
and lack of evidence prove the conspiracy. You're
not talking to someone who rezende their way into
their belief and you're not going to be able to
reason them out of it. Conspiratorial thinking
as opposed to healthy skepticism. Conspiratorial
thinking is immune to contradictory evidence or
lack of evidence. Altogether, the cover up is
so perfect they cover it up all the evidence and
we can't find it. That's part of the conspiracy.
A Peter Bogosian refers to this in his book as
Dogs Duck Sarcastic Closure. It's a belief or
system of beliefs that resists revision at a
systemic structural level. This is often the
problem with religious beliefs based on so-called
sacred texts. Hey, this is true because the
sacred text says so and the sacred text is sacred.
Well, what proof do you have that the sacred text
is really the word of God? Well, you read the
sacred text and it says this is a sacred text
and it's the word of God. OK, well, right. But
is there something from outside the sacred text
that tells us this really is a sacred text? Well,
no. I mean, but that's part of the problem. Of
course not. Of course. Of course, we have to go to
the sacred text to see if it tells us that it is a
sacred text. That is that's a closed circle. You
can never pierce that. And it's a very important
lesson for something to be on the lookout for.
And it's also funny because Lou Dobbs is so close.
He's so close. You know, I've been repeating
this stuff for months and we just can't find
any actual evidence. Why not? Maybe I'm wrong,
but he doesn't get there. Instead, it's explained
to me how they've kept the evidence hidden from
us for so long. And I don't know, maybe someone in
maybe someone in his audience heard that and
said, oh, maybe there's no evidence because
there's really no evidence, because it's not true.
I don't know. But it's funny to see the gears
sort of the gears start grinding. But they got
jammed up as Lou Dobbs was thinking it through.